buenas tardes en realidad lo que existe
es un desinterés de la población con la
clase política que está desprestigiada
por la corrupción que ha salpicado a sus
principales líderes muchos peruanos no
prefirieron arriesgarse a ser digamos a
contagiarse con el cob y 19 en los
centros de sufragio porque la vacuna no
ha llegado a los miembros de mesa
entonces prefirieron quedarse en sus
casas
precisamente los sondeos de opinión no
son encabezados en su mayor parte mejor
dicho las preferencias por los
candidatos presidenciales sino más bien
por los indecisos
la mayoría de encuestadora registra un
30 por ciento de indecisos y este es
otro de los factores por los cuales la
población está digamos preocupada antes
de salir a ser miembro de mesa o votar
se preocupa más por no llevar el comida
a la casa la vacuna años llegaron en
tiempo establecido a los miembros de
mesa y ese es uno de los principales
motivos por los retrasos
desplegado molestia y sobre todo una
situación incómoda a los adultos mayores
que le toca el primer turno y la jornada
francisco pero en el país el voto es
obligatorio entre los 18 y los 70 años
sabemos que hay unas multas para que
para quienes no asistan a votar sin
embargo pero está atravesando como usted
lo decía el peor momento por cuenta de
la pandemia hay alguna modificación de
las autoridades al respecto respecto a
estas multas o las personas que tengan
ese miedo de salir de casa
existe mucha preocupación porque en las
últimas 24 horas
perú ha batido su récord de contagios
con 384 decesos por día en el país
alrededor de 500 mil peruanos solamente
han recibido la vacuna contra el cob y
19 es por eso que las autoridades
tratando de prever una situación adversa
establecieron protocolos de bioseguridad
para que los peruanos salieran a votar
se establecieron que se emplean
mascarillas protectores faciales así
también como el uso de lapiceros
personales pero la preocupación es
participar en los sondeos participar en
esta contienda electoral o sufrir un
contagio del coi 19 y como ningún
miembro de mesa está vacunado muchos
están todavía en ese dilema